this is what I do I'm an undercover
narcotics agent I sit with murderers and
bateman
Washington wants the biggest bust of
history Pablo Escobar and his main
distributor Roberto al que no Mazur
you're partnering with Abreu I think
we've been doing this backwards we've
been following the drug to get the bad
guys but if we chase the money we need
to find new undercover identities look
at this Falcone look at the date
yeah do the math I'd be 77 years old
that's not right let the reading craggly
here we go Babu seller welcome to a life
of crime
let's do this welcome to the United
States these mental illness all the
money for the cartel I need a
face-to-face with your boss it was an
audition you got the part so mr. musalla
what can you do for me
she's my present for you tonight mr. Bob
I'm engaged
so are you kidding me a fiance Bob meet
your soon-to-be wife Kathy Earths Bob
maser I wish you many happy years damn I
need a fiance have you ever had your
palm read destiny has larger in a horse
than biggest money launderer in the US I
thought it was me you messed this up
you'll kill you and it will make you die
four days
I do not do business under threat
unfortunately you are not in a position
to dictate terms to the
this is a path one wrong move and we're
dead my business there is no loyalty to
never ends well
are you in danger from Pablo Escobar you
have a chance to take them all down
a certain situation I have to ask myself
what a bad man